et
bien bonjour en diagonale tv toujours
sur le championnat du monde aujourd'hui
avec jean louis ii chabanon bovins luc
bonjour stéphane richer manon grand
maître international français a plus
trop présents sur le circuit il ya
maintenant plus tôt dans la partie je
dirais plutôt entreprises des échecs
photos cochonnes la partie entraînements
surtout entraînements donc oui j'ai
décidé de
dédié donc l'entraînement du jeu
d'échecs et donc je travaillais
actuellement pour les sites l'échec
academy ni d'aucune école d'échecs
interactive sur internet ça fait chic
academy vous conseillons aussi pour
apprendre notamment avoir des cours par
internet avec le casque audio un grand
maître au bout du fil oui tout à fait
donc un maximum de contenu qui permet
donc aux gens d'apprendre les échecs
quel que soit leur niveau des cours des
cours en direct sur le net
et puis évidemment aucun contenu des
fiches de cours et quelques vidéos à
télécharger plus évidemment les fameuses
vidéos de diagonale bien sûr alors
championnat du monde
scandale avec cette histoire de
protestation de topalov accepté par la
commission d'appel de la fidh pour des
histoires de toilette utilisé par
cramique alors quand on en a parlé lors
des émissions précédentes avec avec
lorlanges qu'elle est toi ton avis sur
ce sont sept cette histoire est donc là
on est à la veille de cette envie
d'avoir cette neuvième partie
quel est ton bilan depuis cette histoire
jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui je dirais
que là ça commence à être un petit peu
pénible cette histoire puisque si on
regarde un petit peu ce qui se passe
c'est que tout simplement
la cram nick vient quand même de perdre
la huitième partie
il n'a pas très bien joué il a perdu
avec les blancs donc on peut quand même
imaginer que cette histoire quand même
le perturbe un petit peu et et puis
et puis c'est quand même quelque chose
qui
qui fait pas une excellente publicité
dans mon des échecs on peut pas dire que
cette histoire de toilette soit le
conflit on dire l'essentiel de ce match
voilà donc c'est clair que quand c'était
l'histoire des départs à psychologue à
l'époque de kornoi c'était quand même
beaucoup plus amusant il y avait la
guerre froide y avait des choses plus
intéressantes quand il ya eu le match
interminable entre karpov et kasparov
le match qui a duré plus de trois mois
c'était quand même amusant mais là c'est
vrai que en plus ce qui me surprend dans
l'attitude de topalov c'est que il ne
fait quasiment aucune déclaration lui
même c'est quand même on a l'impression
qu'il a
une équipe c'est une sorte de pantin qui
est manipulé par par dana love son
manager ouais c'est vrai et ça je trouve
ça quand même assez mais c'est assez
curieuse est ce que finalement c'est pas
bien joué de leur côté c'est à dire que
son manager à swanton certaines ont dû
dire à top alors ne te concerne que sur
le jeu ne parle que du jeu et laisse-moi
gérer les autres aspects et du coup
chacun connaît son rôle alors que
peut-être kramnik puisse y disperser en
essayant de se justifier lui-même et de
finalement a perdu peut-être une partie
de sa concentration et son énergie il
aurait peut-être dû laisser lui même
aussi son manager gérer ce genre de
problème qui était hors horrifique et
mais c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé il
laissait son manager mais bon il est
intervenu un peu plus puisqu'il est
évidemment travnik c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui s'exprime et puis qui doit
affronter deux fronts genre de situation
le seul problème la seule chose qu'on
pourrait reprocher kramnik
c'est peut-être d'avoir été un peu trop
gentil dans cette situation un peu trop
un peu trop laxiste il aurait dû être
beaucoup plus
on dire beaucoup plus
e
affirmer un peu plus sa volonté et
protester de manière un peu plus un peu
plus de dire ne pas accepter de
reprendre le match avec cette histoire
de point par forfait ben je dirais
presque ça je pense que krainik aurait
dû aurait dû dire que déjà ils
n'auraient pas dû continuer le match
sent qu'il ya des excuses officielles
parce qu'il faut quand même avouer
qu'implicitement il a été accusé de
tricherie oui c'est quelque chose que
l'on peut pas accepter c'est quelque
chose je veux dire on joue on est on est
quand même considéré comme l'un des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète on a
battu kasparov et on accuser tricherie
je trouve que c'est quand même quelque
chose qui ne faut pas accepter qu rami
aurait dû insister pour avoir des
excuses officielles voire même exclure
toute intervention de daniel offe qui
n'a plus rien à faire a les listes à moi
mais ce n'était pas simplement de
soissons c'était simplement une
protestation ont donné à la commission
d'appel est ce que ce n'est pas la
commission d'appel qui a fait une faute
en acceptant une protestation qui en
plus était hors délai apparemment parce
qu'elles doivent être faites les
réclamations de doit être faite au plus
tard deux heures après les parties là ça
a été fait le lendemain en plus
normalement dans le contrat il est
spécifié que les changements de
conditions du jeu doivent faire
l'approbation des deux joueurs ce qui
n'a pas été le cas et que et on avait
bien vu d'ailleurs que cette commission
d'appel à à démissionner d'ailleurs donc
elle a été complètement dissoute et est
refaite avec des nouveaux membres donc
est-ce que c'est pas aussi la preuve que
c'est plutôt la commission d'appel qui
fait une faute à la limite qu'on
suspecte quelqu'un tricherie bon à la
limite on a presque le droit de le faire
mais c'est pas soin d'eux
d'être juge et partie donc il ya ya ya
il ya un juge qui est la commission
d'appel qui décident est-ce que c'est
pas la commission qu'il a fait la fois
de finalement il ya évidemment il ya une
faute qui a été fait par les accusateurs
ils ont les ordinateurs ont très bien
fait les choses au niveau médiatique
c'est le thomas est très très bien
préparé ça c'est incontestable mais il
se trouve que ils ont
ils ont oublié une chose importante
c'est que
c'est que c'était un match très tendu
déjà de par son histoire quand même
c'est un match de réunification donc
bien sûr il ya des enjeux énormes dans
ce match et donc ils auraient dû quand
même prévoir
être plus vigilant donc choisir une
véritable commission d'appel à la base
avec de vrais professionnels de ce genre
de compétition et des conflits 20 des
spécialistes de la négociation et je
crois que ce n'était pas le cas mais je
reproche tout de même
enfin jason que je reproche la chronique
ne pas avoir montré ne pas avoir affirmé
son statut de meilleur joueur mondial
puisque d'un des meilleurs joueur
mondial puis vip mondiaux puisque face à
face à une telle situation il faut
vraiment être direct et je crois que
sur sur ce point de vue les meilleurs
joueurs de la planète sont tout à fait
d'accord
beaucoup ont essayé de le défendre mais
c'était à lui de vraiment de dire non on
peut pas me parler comme ça ça ne se
fait pas ouais je crois qu'elle kasparov
si kasparov avait été dans cette
situation
j'ose imaginer sa réaction j'ose
imaginer que ce refus est un véritable
ce qu'on achète certainement
kramnik c'est vrai qu'on peut à la
rigueur ne pas lui reprocher on voit pas
lui reprocher d'être quelqu'un de très
gentil très sympathique mais c'est quand
même réservé le droit d'attaquer la date
à qui la fille de oui post match oui
mais c'est quand même un choix qui qui
est une sorte de compromis c'était une
situation où il ne fallait pas donner de
compromis il fallait être
il fallait efficace direct or la fin du
match peut-être de lui donnera raison la
lettre police père et il faut espérer
pour faire du match donne raison et de
toute façon le bilan de ce match c'est
que
topalov qui est quand même un excellent
joueur
est-ce qu'il va pas souffrir d'une
baisse d'image m'a carrément de respect
des steam a carrément je crois que là
maintenant surtout que
ça tout les échecs sont de plus en plus
médiatique sur internet je crois que
kramnik là
bon il ya qu'à voir un petit peu les
survols un petit peu ce qui s'écrit à
droite à gauche pour pour pour
comprendre plus grave ni écolo topalov
maintenant est
beaucoup moins populaire que par kadrige
que juste avant le match c'est quand
même incroyable et tout ça parce que
finalement c'est le pantin de tana il
offre au niveau je dirais pas au niveau
échec mais par contre au niveau
niveau image il est complètement
manipulé par son manager et c'est donc
évidemment il se concentre échec mais
mais là il a accepté des choses qu'il ne
fallait pas accepter d'accord très bien
voilà donc la ligue 2 jean luc chavanon
sur cette crise qui frappe le
championnat du monde et donc tous les
échecs puisqu'on est ici à la tête ces
chèques mondiaux alors quand même et à
des courses après huit partis comme on
l'a vu sur les émissions précédentes et
bien à égalité
égalité donc après trois fois les noirs
pour kramnik puisque donc il avait
manqué sept parties par forfait donc il
a fait forfait
pour protester en fait trois fois les
noirs en plus il a déjà envoyé trois
fois et noir puisque il ya eu deux fois
l'an pour topalov et ensuite on est
arrivé en milieu de match et on a
inversé les couleurs puisqu'il ya deux
sortes de millimages c'est à l'intérieur
du match angers sco kramnik a démarré
avec les blancs et amis match on a
inversé les couleurs ce qui a donné
cette cette chose un peu unique dans
l'histoire du jeu d'échec on vous la
chronique a eu trois fois de suite les
noirs et quand il ay blanc donc à cette
huitième partie il ya hyper comme on l'a
vu lors de l'émission sur la huitième
que nous habitons à revoir donc on
arrive maintenant 7,8 neuvième partie
maintenant l'égalité parfaite de
victoire pour granby deux victoires pour
topalov dans une acquis sur tapis vert
sans jouer mais score égal donc de 4
partout et donc on arrive à la fin du
match puisqu'il reste quatre partis
maintenant 12 12 parties en tout cas ce
match éventuellement des tie-breaks
puisqu'il y aura pas de vainqueur
désigné en cas de match nul il y aura
des tie-breaks lan parties rapides on
n'en est pas là mais il reste plus que
quatre parties il faut bouger topalov
maintenant les plans d'alain de viable
match devenait extrêmement tendue tout
de suite on passe à cette neuvième
partie de ce championnat du monde unifié
2006 entre topalov et wlan mercredi est
au pas l'offre encore une fois donc
c'est le match 2 des 4 il joue le plan
de la dame sait vraiment si l ouverture
de ce championnat je vais pas dire le
contraire je joue des cats donc pour moi
c'est un excellent coup cette façon
c'est un coût qui permet de placer ses
pièces
personnellement c'est pas un coup je
conseille aux débutants je penserais
plutôt aux débutants de jouer eux quatre
premiers coups mais puisque 4 permet
d'avoir des ou le coup droit il voit là
je dirais que ça permet d'avoir des
parties un petit peu plus animée mais
des quatre cantons a du métier c'est un
coût qui permet de qui évite de prendre
des risques qui permet de placer ses
pièces tranquillement et de développer
sa stratégie en limitant le contre jeu
adverse et les complications tactique
d'accord alors dessin classique et après
ces quatre grammy douce et 6 non
courantes de nouveau dans un système de
type slave avec ce faire nos courses et
6 qui jouait maintenant y compris par
topalov c'est comme ça qu'il a gagné en
huitièmes donc c'est aussi l ouverture
de ce match en cognant la défense lave
au lycée la défense cela vous le
capitaine enfin les positions classiques
apparemment donc là les joueurs non
n'ont pas l'intention de jouer des
ouvertures moderne ou hyper moderne
comme la neige au beach ils ont pas
envie d'abandonner le centre pour le
récupérer plus tard ils veulent donc
jouer de manière la plus rationnelle et
crame nick donc évidemment cramé qui
part avec un capital expérience face à
topalov
assez positif dans leurs confrontations
passées donc et surtout avec ce genre
d'ouverture donc c'est pour ça qu'il a
employés et jusqu'à présent c'est vrai
que dans le match ça lui a plutôt réussi
plutôt réussi tout à fait alors qu'harry
f3 quel est le sisp antranik et l'a13
donc c'est la fameuse variante on
récupère le pion sait qu'à tout de suite
on veut pas on veut pas donner au noir
la possibilité de le prendre on a déjà
vu des autres possibilités donc on va
passer là dessus
et là vous et cinq neutres annick donc
fou et 5 ou le fou sort tout de suite
ici f5 lojeski si déjà jean luc ya pas
d possibilité de profiter de sortie
rapide de ce fou qui affaiblit un peu
les casques blancs de ce côté là par les
coups comme dam des trois
sont possibles oui lyon que l'on peut
jouer dmb 3 c'est un coût qui est tout à
fait possible j'imagine que dans cette
position les noirs jouent le ku'damm b6
pour son 2e des trois
pour jouer on s'émeut répondrai
simplement parle parle asymétrique voilà
tout à fait et l'état sont visés comme
ça on défendrait le clan des sept
d'accord donc ya pas de point
particulier en fait il n'y a pas de
problème particulier je voudrais juste
revenir en arrière
okubo f5 donc quand on joue quand le
topalov jour 3 je voudrais juste
expliquer une chose c'est que dans cette
position donc il ya quand même plusieurs
embranchements a montré il ya le coup
dans cette position il ya le coup aussi
ce donc le coc aussi ce qui est
intéressant aussi hélas probablement
topalov pourrait placer donc son
cavalier le cavalier donc le cavalier
bea sur la case c3 pour obtenir une
position proche de la partie qui a été
jouée récemment
donc mai
j'imagine aussi
qu'il a peut-être l'attention cette
position de placer le cavalier sur des
deux donc c'est un développement assez
assez dangereux pour pour les pour les
noirs puisque là les noirs ne peuvent
pas obtenir les positions classiques
avec cavaliers b17
donc les positions classiques
puisque dans sa position après fou des
trois donc on va jouer
17 foot et 3 par exemple dans cette
position les noirs peuvent difficilement
prendre le pion sur ces quatre le pion à
callière reprendre parce que cavalier
reprendre et et donc on a et b d2 c'est
un coût qui est assez dangereux donc
c'est probablement une position que
krainik a voulu éviter et sinon il ya
d'autres possibilités sur e3 si on
revient un peu en arrière le coup que
qu'affectionne etienne bacrot mais qui
qui réussit plutôt bien à topalov donc
sur trois c'est comme trois ans pour
jour très important oui c'est le coût à
6 à 6 donc le coup à six pour
éventuellement verrouiller les dames par
bessac donc préparer la poussée b5 le
pion béquilles mais n'ose avancer sur
des simples et se garder la possibilité
de sortir le fou ces huit un peu plus
tard d'accord ça se font plus tard ou
alors donc alors on va revenir la partie
donc après fou et 5 donc il a été
finalement choisie
car elle et ses trois enfants
développent et se développe aussi ce
maintenant plus fous sorti c'est
toujours plus agréable de jouer aussi ce
que je vous ai déjà sortis et là tout de
suite topalov toof sort un coup de
un peu surprenant puisqu'il met un k way
à la bande en jouant cavalier h4 veut
visiblement échangé ce fou oui donc un
coup surprenant mais un coût très
important dans cette position puisque le
fond f5 et exerce une pression assez
désagréable si on ramène le cas veille
en f3 juste pour montrer donc voilà sur
la diagonale oui le font avec 5 à
contrôler toute la diagonale blanche
donc il est bien placé y contre les
quatre centrales et ou si on les change
par replaçant le fou sur la case d3
donc
on obtient oui voilà donc si on joue ce
genre de couronnes et charles
d'entremont fou contre voilà en échange
on échange les fous et après on n'a plus
le fou sur ces ans la position a
tendance à être assez équilibrée des
trois salles échanges un peu trop pièces
donc cavalier h4 c'est la continuation
classique dans cette position il faut
tout faire pour se débarrasser du fou
voilà alors cramique lui bombay après
réflexion choisi de mettre son feu sur
les 15 6 voilà parce que faire prendre
un fcn qui aurait sorti un pion du
centre est ici et là tout de suite créé
par la fusion pose pas de questions ils
échangent et voilà c'est fait la petite
combine de topalov est finie le fou a
disparu et on chante on peut noter quand
même que les noms une belle colonna
quand même acquis c'est clair que les la
tour donc exerce une pression sur la
colonne h mais le foie disent pas mais
il faut disparu donc là pour l'instant
on a on a concédé la paire de fou pour
avoir toujours un centre très solide on
contrôle bien les quatre centrales et
donc là après nouveauté c'est ça de
topalov quoi la main c'est une nouveauté
donc là c'est le moment important de la
partie c'est là où topalov donc
à trois jours à troyes alors je donne
petite nouveauté enfin tout cas grosse
nouveauté c'est une grosse nouveauté à
face a déjà été jouée quand même c'est
très très peu traité presque jouer c'est
une grosse nouveauté c'est un coup très
important pour le match puisqu'après ce
petit coup de pions qui est qui et pèse
ce n'est pas très facile à expliquer
mais je vais juste essayer montrer un
petit peu plus tard pourquoi il est là
on va la jouer ce coup là avec ce coup
de pions là je crois que bon il montre
qu'il a préparé quelque chose contre la
slave donc ils essayent de faire peur à
son adversaire en plus il choisit un
moment psychologique pour faire peur
puisque c'est si on regarde bien c'est
donc l'avant dernière partie avec les
blancs will fall of c'est vrai c'est
l'avant dernière partie avec les plantes
topalov crâne nickel spéciale the slave
alors la question qui pose par ce coup
c'est déjà lui le meur difficulté à
cette partie et en même temps il va le
ils veulent faire gamberger j'imagine
que que lors de la 11eme partie kramnik
va se poser la question quoi jouer
contre des cas contre dsk je joue là
cela ou pas ce coup là alors c'est quoi
le dit sous contrôle cette case évident
donc on empêche tout b4 essentiellement
on empêche tout b4 donc ça c'est c'est
une chose importante
dans cette position les noirs non par ok
on voit qu'il ya le si on regarde bien
il ya le roi au centre donc le roi peu
rauque et soit allé le roi avec la
tourache 8 soit halal dames avec la
torah 8
en juin coup comme à troyes quelque part
on dissuade les noirs de faire le grand
roque oui parce qu'on pourrait jouer
ensuite b4 et bessin pour casser tout de
suite attaqué le roi qui serait là voilà
un cas trois ça permet de jouer cette
variante très très rapidement et donc ça
pourrait forcer les noirs aller de
l'autre côté alors que n'ont pas
vraiment envie de l'autre côté
puisqu'ils ont une colle à 10,6 ouverte
ou qui paraît var et laisser leurs torts
outils en fait par exemple il faut aussi
trouver une place pour le roi alors à
trois et un coût important ils auraient
pu éventuellement être décalé par le
coup que l'on connaît habituellement g3
mais je crois que toi pas la favec
complètement envie de d'éviter le coup
sous b 4 mai la vente qui suit donc la
vente que j'ai expliqué non c'est juste
avec g3 alors si les blancs allaient
jouer au lieu de trois le coude le coût
habituel s'il avait joué j'ai trois
clubs donc normal voilà donc là les
noirs se développe par cavalier bd c'est
dans cette position là sur pièce il
garde la possibilité de sortir le fou
sur des 6 ou sur recettes ou sur b4 on
apprend le foot les noirs et là dans
cette position donc le coût habituel
c'est fou j'ai 2
donc ça c'est la position habituelle et
après fou j'ai deux ont joué dans cette
position dépensé quel point c'est
logique voilà donc le fou comprend pas
le pion on va essayer de voile et ont
géré dépensé 4 est en général après les
les noirs jouent dameuse pour récupérer
le plein d'eau récupère le pion voilà si
on essaie de le protéger et non 6 6 et
emprise du foin mais dans cette position
bon je vais juste expliquer à tout petit
peu comment ça commence à se comment ça
se transforme après un coup comme dame
eux deux en général les les noirs
maintenant vont essayer d'obtenir une
formation typique de la slave à savoir
donc par exemple assez leur flou sur la
case des six d'un procès cat et préparez
donc la poussée e 6 e 5 en climatique la
poussée thématiques pour soit isolé le
pion soit ouvrir le jeu mais il se
trouve que dans cette position-là père
de fou donc les deux fous là ne sont pas
très efficaces d'accord donc on a du mal
à optimiser sa et il est parti qui se
joue là dessus sont souvent équilibré
d'accord voilà donc topalov en jouant à
3 on revient à ce combat 3 donc on joue
en a trois on peut continuer la partie
de soi sont les explications sans
voiture terreïs et b17 oui ou un coup
classique à coups de règlements
classique g3 et là évidemment on voit
que sur dépensé 400 attention
c'est de reprendre du fou mais sur ce
qu'ils pensent et quatre dans ce cas là
il reprendrait vous voilà donc
évidemment le coup j'ai trois n'est pas
le meilleur coût par rapport à la prise
du fou mais de toute façon là on imagine
que rapidement le pion de 3go avancé sur
la case de 4 et que la paire de fous
plus le centre va quand même commencer à
un centre aux voix là depuis un centre
au plus la paire de fou donc le fouet le
phocéen et le pussycat ça fait beaucoup
ça fait beaucoup la famille asper de fou
toujours un avantage la fin de partie on
ne le dira jamais assez la banque
l'après c3 fou hausse est en fait une
petite
interversion beaucoup donc force est oui
et là tous peuvent jouer le coup
surprenant f4f 4 qui vante qui affaiblit
un peu
un tout petit peu le roi quand même
puisqu'on en est même tout près de moi
mais bon qui contrôle par contre est
très fortement ici une espèce de
structure
quirky rappelle la hollandaise où le mur
hollandais quand le béton comme on
appelle ça le stonewall voilà le
stonewall le mur de pierres des murs de
pierres sur 15 mois ici ont accès
extrêmement solide mais c'est un peu
surprenant de ce qu'ils voient les
joueurs jouent rarement ce genre de
structure en fait oui j'ai rarement mais
là dans cette position s'est justifié
par le contrôle de la case de la case
centrale à gaz de 5 le problème toujours
ce gentil tueur c'est le fou alors le
foot joue pas il est complètement donc
il va falloir imaginer qu'on jouera
quatre plus tard mais une grosse
surprise de cette partie c'est quand
même topalov joue
mais tous ses pions se rendre mais tous
ses pions sur noir jouent une ouverture
très très original mais un seul pion
c'est celui ci question blanc est là
dans cette position donc un plan
ambitieux puisqu'il s'installe quand
même beaucoup depuis au centre et donc
ils menacent d'étouffer rapidement son
adversaire et
cramique dans cette position je pense
qu'il a été il a été un peu bouleversé
quoi part parce par ce plan il n'a pas
su il a été choqué il a su réagir il n'a
pas su réagir il n'a pas su réagir dans
sa position puisque c'est vrai que
envoie le goût de kramnik voyant france
est fatiguée surprenant alors des
princes et cadeaux classe et on peut
considérer c'est la première ça
ressemble à une erreur parce que oui
c'est une erreur c'est grâce à quoi
c'est un coût qui n'est pas vraiment
pour empêcher le 4 on peut pas empêcher
les blancs de prendre tout le centre
avec trois pions énorme donc fait
kramnik ne pas paniquer on s'éclaire
c'est bizarre quand même de fait il est
surpris il a surpris tous les
spécialistes avec un coup pareil voilà
on se dit quand même que les normes
doivent contrôler cette case de 4 enfin
c'est ce qu'on ça paraît logique et
quand ils le contrepoids de l'akazu 5
oui
qui est qui est vraiment là tout
l'appui des noirs dans cette position si
cette case là et en prenant ces quatre
bons non seulement on libérera 7,4 et en
plus si on permet aux fous de sortir en
un coup alors qu'en général on prend
plutôt une fois que le fou a déjà joué
donc sa part elle double erreur de ce
point de vue là c'est quand même assez
bizarre parce qu'il est arrivé premier
set cette position
c'est
déjà du mal à comprendre mais je crois
que je crois qu'il n'avait pas envie de
faim moi j'imagine je sais pas on peut
envisager plusieurs coups on peut
envisager soit par amp le coup à cinq
pour
contrôler un petit peu l'avancé des
pions éventuel allèles dame avant de
faire petit rock on peut envisager
d'abaisser cette se développer pour
garder la possibilité de faire soit le
petit rock soit le grand roque met donc
attendons un peu de voir ce qui se passe
que joué certains coups mais
mais abandonner le sainte par dépenser 4
donc abandonné donc semblé tendu se
sentent 60 très étonnant c'est assez
curieux qu'une conception un peu
curieuse et on va voir d'ailleurs que ça
va s'avérer assez assez douteux après
fou prend ses quatre petits roms tout de
suite donc là l'impression que je vous
kramnik la jouer des coups rapides un
peu plus réfléchi
parce que le petit rock aussi on y suit
derrière quasiment immédiatement on voit
traîner de la tour qui était pas si mal
placée en suite puisqu'elle contrôle et
quand une belle colonnes sony ouverte du
coup maintenant se retrouve bloqué et on
se demande presque finalement que si si
si si le roi est bien de ce côté là s'il
aurait mieux pas fallut même le laisser
au centre en attendant que les blancs
prennent eux mêmes leur décision voilà
peut-être pas là le choix qu'il a je
peux dire que parce qu'il n'a plus
vraiment le choix qui ont maintes fois
il a plus vraiment le choix le il faut
bien en plus il a permis il permet à
l'adversaire de pousser au centre donc
il peut pas garder son rôle alors on
encore la suite ils peuvent mais bon
quel sens tu en voilà le cap tout de
suite moi c'est donc maintenant on y est
donc langage évidemment protège très
bien quatre et là ça y est on a un super
centre face à un seul pion central trois
fois j'aurai plus en plus formés marche
d'espions qui contrôle la casse de 5
donc ses fesses à fait pourquoi c'est un
espace rouleau compresseur en tout cas
l'avantagé des espaces ils manifestent
on peut dire que les blancs un avantage
peut-être pas encore défini pas évident
à trouver les dira et durable
si on regarde bien sûr en position
connaissant topaloff
non seulement il a un avantage durable
mais en plus dans sa position c'est que
on sait qu'il va pas loupé son
adversaire topalov adore avoir
l'initiative va jusqu'au bout c'est pas
le genre à faire du le difficile
difficile de voir où est le con tre jeu
des noirs dans cette position ces cinq
est difficilement jouable actuellement
puisque si les noirs jouer sur quatre
jouer ces cinq les blu pousserait le
pion des mois et si on jouait ces cinq
on pousserait le camp des pour ce que
nous avions passé oui on aurait dû en
passer protégé ici par le cas donc même
en cas de prisons reprend du plan et en
un vrai qu'ils ont passé soutenu par des
pièces énorme donc très difficilement
attaquable oui peut-être là une petite
astuce quand même à montrer mais juste
donc c'est après ces cinq là c'est ça on
pousserait le pion des et si par exemple
les noirs joue cavalier
cavaliers b6 si ses attaquants le fou et
le pion donc je pense que là les noirs
les blancs ramènerait leur fou sur la
case à deux donc ici pour regarder
contrôle sur tesla et sur pure prend des
cinq peut-être que les blancs dans cette
position il semble aurait envie de jouer
le coup eux cinq d'abord d'accord le 5
ça ici alors avec le cavalier à vide à
bouger par exemple henri iv mais là ça
va être un petit peu de délits car un
peu difficile quand essais en 17 et la
cavalier prend des 5 hélas le fouet de
et royal se fout est énorme puisqu'il
est sûre case blanche alors que tous les
pions son show case noire donc il est
énorme est-ce que tout et tout les types
de cas sont contrôlés par les pions par
le fou en cuisson voit très bien qu'il
vise le roi ce roi qui en plus peut pas
vraiment se réfugier sur le clonage
puisqu'il sera toujours attaquée par
peut-être par ici mais ici par une dame
par exemple qui pourra faire un petit
échec mortels donc très difficile quand
même très difficile ça l'est davantage
en plus on le cavalier d5 est bon on
peut soit rester mais aussi peut prendre
le fou sur 7 alors on va revenir faire
partie des menaces et prendre les paires
de fouet si on va revenir à 4 et la
cramif choisi pessac il a vu que c'est
ça ne marchait pas il a choisi notre
plan
pour réagir donc on va en fait là les
noirs son époux fait beaucoup de mal à
trouver des idées et donc il joue
b55 en bessin qui n'arrange pas sa
position mais bon il faut bien jouer
quelque chose et
et éventuellement éventuellement il pose
quand même une petite question par
rapport aux fous c'est vrai que si le
fou cette fois sur des saints qui a
peut-être un petit piège c'est que s'il
faut rester sur la diagonale à 2 g 8 par
exemple ici oui par exemple peut-être
qu'il laisse errer de glisser le coupé
quatre pour peut-être par à 5 d'abord
pour un handicap pour éventuellement
attaqué pion aux quatre
avaient coché ce pion serait faible et
cassis caraïbes où je vis dans les
pionts centrale est perdu enfin il
voudrait peut-être provoqué la poussée
des pions le 5 pour obtenir une la case
des cinq pour cent cavaliers s'il
provoque ça évidemment il est délicat
centrale n'est sûr donc mais mes topalov
place sont fous sur la belle case à 2 e
2 sur deux noms qui revient en e2
topaloff est la chronique alors est ce
qu est ce qu ont un plan pour kramnik
aurait pas été possible c'est de jouer
le coup à six agents lui pour préparer
la poussée 5
d'abord joué ensuite carélie v6 pour
bien contrôler les cases des cinq
peut-être même rajouté après derrière
j'ai pas la dame pourrait bouger on
pourrait mettre une tour derrière bien
contrôlé et après jouer pour la pousser
ses seins qui qui serrait de d'éliminer
un des pions centraux je pense que dans
une position les pièces blanches sont
trop bien placé donc si on joue à six
pour je sais 5 c'est roland will et
blanc peuvent déjà placé leurs fous sur
e3 où placer l'autre fou sur f3 aussi
c'est ce flou sur f3 qui contrôlent
encore bien la cause des saints qui on
pourra toujours jouer dessins des cinq
voire au 5 mai voire 5 ans a attaqué le
cavalier attaqué la tour parce qu'ils le
font avec 3 et face à la tour et le cas
il pourrait venir ici
sauf qu'on peut on gagner sur ses 55 ans
gagnera un pion
la place sur foot365 harry sur ces cinq
mesures de 5 à 2,5 et la tourette à
l'attaqué à cinq fois la page web
puisque un fou il est contrôlé deux fois
tout à fait alors on va voir a presque
choisi notre ami cramique alors qu'on
fait signe henry que de temps avant ce
que le crâne il ajouté quatre voilà donc
il essaie de perturber peu topalov
bon mais on voit que le problème c'est
que après le coup de normal de topalov à
prendre b4 reprend b4 devient chronique
se retrouver deux pions faible ici voilà
donnant pas ce qu'ils sont ils sont
isolés ce qu'on appelle des pujols et
donc ses deux cibles c'est un peu pour
l'instant la ruine de la position noir
ça va être ses deux pions voilà donc une
structure
structure pas terrible dégueulasse comme
on les enferme et après fou prend b4
donc il faut quand même éviter la menace
directe cavaliers prend le 4 oui alors
la menace évidemment ces cavaliers prend
1,4 tout de suite puisque ce car les
trous et une note moyenne tout à fait le
fou b4 le fou attaquant le roi donc on
peut l'appareil de plusieurs façons par
contre petit rock qui enlève le clouage
petit rock mais qui n'enlèverait pas la
prise du pion puisqu'on pourrait prendre
d'abord le cavalier et prendre le pion à
on va le voir tout de suite maintenant
sur ptitblog il ya plus évidemment la
veille par quatre mais on joue on prend
d'abord le cavalier commence par fiat
avait les visent kamal et prend 2,4 et
voilà on est gardien de sion on ne gagne
un pion aux açores de questions on peut
revenir dans la partie on va revenir
dans la partie donc faut f3 logique donc
de topalov je protège concurrents je lui
mon fou sur une belle case qui en plus
va me servir à protéger le case blanche
du côté de mon roi parce que je vais
faire un petit rock on voyait il est
revenu à une position un peu plus
en accord avec la structure de pions là
ils jouent des jeux des coûts qui sont
très très logique très classique très
logique très classique ces pièces d'un
v6 de chroniques à l'or avec les lits
des alors là déjà un coût qui semble un
peu
un peu olé olé où là aussi
c'est un coup à l'éolien on s'attendait
plutôt un coup comme ces cinq tout de
suite essayé de simplifier la situation
centrale
ouais mais c'est ça qui aurait toujours
le respect son attaque la tour bruxelles
mais qu'à vallée des saints qui est
possible maintenant puisque le cavalier
cloud et donc il ya plus le plus gagnon
peut-être c'était une possibilité est
plutôt plutôt le coup peut-être dessin
qu'avait fait peur chronique est ce que
c'est vraiment grave de laisser passer
un pion central par exemple sur des cinq
qui on prend des 5
et là on jouait sans doute aux cinq
qui comprend des scènes je sais pas mais
surtout comprendre des saints qui n'en
peuvent plus on prend de dire gagner
cheikh évidemment dans les clous laroque
est sidérant ça donnerait pas mal de jeu
je pense que si on regarde bien la
position la paix après ces cinq
là intéressant c'est en tout cas
peut-être plus que la partie peut-être
fou ou trois peut-être
tank ou kung fu ou 3-1 développement de
foot ou simplement mais dans ce cas là
on échange un pion qui est faible par un
pion central donc calais prévu topalov
sur ces cinq là ont tous posé la
question c'est en tout cas le coup qu'on
attendait dans cette partie plutôt que
le coût de krabi qui on va le voir va
lui poser des problèmes
assez assez difficile c'est vrai c'est
vrai que ce coup ces seuils peut-être
c'était le moment de jouer 6 5 vous
allez réagir fallait réagir et peut-être
c'est le moment c'était le moment qui
t'a pas du travail après ça que la
position est quand même compliquée
puisque cavaliers d525 cavaliers des
cinq ans et celle d'être je me fous des
deux aussi aux tractations et en fout
des 2 par exemple
il a
vraiment prendre aussi une position qui
semble normal on peut
oui alors ya le problème de ce thème
animé on peut le protéger par exemple
ici par cavalier b6 donc tout est bien
protégé un dessin et on voit bien que ce
pion des cas de l'assèchement g contre
lyon xi sign go qu'il arrive oui
mais enfin quand quelque chose qui
quelque chose qui ne va pas trop dans sa
position de toute façon il pourrait y
avoir un cavalier franck cavallier
cavalli prend peut-être fou prend b4 la
lequel il peut pas reprendre évidemment
à cause du fou qui attaqueraient la tour
donc il faut prendre du plomb mais dans
ce cas là on garde le pion central mais
ce que finances calais par un excellent
joker voilà voilà voilà peut-être la
possibilité karaté karaté peut-être
vladimir kramnik mais bon évidemment
avec maintenant il ya quand même
structure de turquie mauvaise ici et
possibilité d' attaques de l'autre côté
alors voilà donc c'était une possibilité
enfin une chronique estimé qu'elles
étaient pas bonnes et donc il a joué sur
fond f3 il n'a pas joué la poussée csn
qui était possible et il a choisi plutôt
d'amd 6 avec l'idée si tu rock et bien
ce pion et cloud voilà c'est que ce pion
pourra pas bouger puisque yohann leroy
derrière et topalov en fait n'a pas eu
peur de le des conséquences
puisqu'il a joué lui même petit rock
quand même voilà et ça c'est toute
l'idée de kravitz qui va pouvoir
s'exprimer mais on va voir quelle est
pas suffisante
en plus là dans cette position après le
coup ces cinq là après table des six il
y aurait cavalcade sur c'est simple tout
de suite je crois que tu aurais cavalli
ac a pas cette position
ou même encore eu 5 5 sur 5 oui pour le
5 d'abord le 5 l'accord la tour et sur
purpan 10,4 pour éventuellement faire
une découverte puisque le grain pour
prendre ici avec échec sur le relais
dames b6 donc qui avec le contenant
cavalia quatre attaques la dame et on
peut pas faire la découverte elle doit
sortir de la négo nal et là il ya un peu
trop de pièces en prêt jusqu'à les
attaques et de foyers trop de pièces
emprise ya la tour aux six nations donc
alors près d'un petit rock à kramnik
joue son idée donc ce qu'ils ont et
cloud et voilà il d'être annick est donc
plutôt que d'avoir à changer les pions
par ces cinq qui posait des problèmes
avec souffle et sa tour en vis-à-vis et
bien ils échangent de l'autre côté
maintenant par le coup ce surprenant au
premier abord eu cinq lits mais son pion
en prison en fait ce pays étant prises
qu'une seule fois par le pur f4 puisque
ce pion ici on le rappelle est cloué à
cause de la dame qui ferait échec au roi
accepte on ne peut pas bouger il est
complètement cloud et on est donc un sac
c'est ce qu'on appelle une réaction
centrale à réaction centrale et on voit
que si les blancs prôné en cinq avaient
tout simplement reprendre et du cavalier
séquence option on peut toujours voir la
jeune attaquant le fou attaquant le
foudre qui menacent d'éliminer le fou et
s'ils font revient sur g2 par exemple
allez les noirs se retrouve maintenant
avec la possibilité de
de la pression sont des cas de continuer
par exemple autour des huîtres des
wilayas menace de prise il surfe le 3 le
cavalier ou cinq souffre ou trois pour
défendre le pion des quatre le grain des
cavaliers viendra sur la case g4 donc
par exemple celui ci attaquant le fou et
on voit que si ce fou sort le pian des
4es perdu voilà ça donne tout le jour
noir donc ça sort est une grosse erreur
évitez donc oser la valeur d'auto pas là
donc il fallait pas prendre congé en
général c'est le seul problème qui a
quand on joue beaucoup des quatre c'est
souvent ce genre de manip de voilà de
d'erreurs mais un minimum de
concentration permet d'être évité tout
ça c'est pour ça qu'il a il a joué il a
joué trois fous et trois logiques de
topalov donc je mets mon fou ici je des
clous un peu déjà ce pion enfin pas
vraiment puisque la dame pourra toujours
prendre le fou avec l'échec est pas
vraiment des clous et donc nous trois
et là bon mais on vous dit pour les
noirs bon mais c'est pas si mal puisque
je suis pas alors évidemment pas obligé
de prendre dans les quatre objets
prendre en éclats tout de suite mais
déjà ce pion peut s'échanger contre
pions des quatre ans point central ce
qui serait quand même 2000 victoire oui
si le pion prend des claques dans cette
position et où j'imagine que topaloff
avait peut-être l'intention de jouer aux
intermédiaires n'ai pas pu le faire tout
de suite puisque le fou de toute façon
en pêche que ce pion bouge oui mais
attention il va y avoir une menace quand
même c'est quand on joue feu 3 on menace
cavaliers à 4 voilà le fameux kayak hat
qui attaquent la dame il doit sortir la
diagonale et le pion des cats sera des
clous et et pour apprendre sur cinq et
après on pourrait faire pour le français
dont il ya une menace tout de suite dans
cette position il ya la besace cavalia 4
donc on peut
le pire aux cinq soit on prend avec le
soit on prend un f4 mais là il ya foule
pour les cartes avec un beau centre on
peut prendre quatre ans garde un super
centre voilà efforts si on prend des
cats a peut être une idée intéressante
mais
j'imagine qu'après un coup comme fou
condé 4 4 voilà je vous répondrais faire
cavalier à 4 aussi possible oui cavale
il ya quatre importantes d'abord pour
contrôler les cases noires par exemple à
deux baies 5 dès maintenant on peut
prendre avec le soin la dame sur le fou
soit avec la dame soit avec le fouet ce
qui est très important dans cette
position donc quand je prends la souris
ouais juste pour montrer que dans sa
position imaginons qu'on prenne avec la
dame
même si je préférerais peut-être prendre
avec la tour avec le fou enfin bon ce
qui est important de voir aussi c'est
l'aspect le jeu positionnelle donc là on
a un fou on à la paire de fou donc ça
c'est un avantage tout à fait et on
fasse on a une mauvaise structure c'est
à dire qu'on a deux pions isolés contre
un allèle dames alors que de ce côté on
a quatre pions contre 3 40 à 3 pions
pour leucate donc là ça constitue déjà
davantage positionnelle voilà donc n'est
davantage positionnelle une majorité les
droits qu'ils s'expriment mieux que la
majorité des noirs à l'aide d'armes et
une paire de fou voilà donc des choses
prennent un gros avantage safari gros
avantages ça fait un programme plage
alors kramnik choisis sur vous ou 3 et
bien d'augmenter la pression dans un
premier temps jouant tour à des huit
voilà augmentant la pression sur ton des
quatre qui pour l'instant ne peut
toujours pas bouger mais évidemment il
ya maintenant la combine de topalov qui
rentrent en jeu mes toiles fabien boeuf
un crâne qui a vu un couple venant on va
voir que ça va ça suffira pas quand même
voter tous ces problèmes près de cavalia
4 le fameux coup pour enlever le clouage
de cette dame sur le client donc va être
obligé de sortir d'ailleurs kramnik la
saur par exemple il a joué en des 8
et là on se rend compte qu'en fait les
prises ici on le sait ne sont pas bonnes
maintenant à cause du vis-à-vis entre la
tour et la dame
oui mais voilà imaginons par exemple si
on prend des cinq croit que en prendre
cinq à l'ars en bons coups puisque le
pion ici protéger papillon et
psychiatres mais non c'est pas grave je
prends quand même avec le cavalier
pourquoi puisque matour attaque avec une
découverte cette fois sur la dame
donc voilà voilà l'idée de
deux chroniques donc je peux quand même
reprendre 25 alors donc après cavaliers
à quatre dames v8 topalov d'abord choisi
d'enlever sa dame voit la dame ces deux
du vis-à-vis tour et maintenant le
problème du tout en scène commence à se
poser il faut que kralik ça y est
échanges sont des 424 sinon le prochain
coup c'est la prise des blancs donc là
alors là c'est le problème qu'à hull kr
amis qu'à ce moment là donc de quelques
comprendre alors logiquement on se
dirige en lui qu'il faut prendre le pion
de d4 qui étions centrale
plutôt que le pion f4 où on se dit qu'on
pourrait ramener encore un pull-over le
centre même si ça ça donne de l'air un
peu froid par exemple a forcé puisque
quelque part quand il y prend le pion
des quatre danses etc enfin si si les
noirs prennent le pire des cas d'après
fo prend des quatre oui
le fouet les les fous sont vraiment très
forts ils doivent tous enfants les
fouilles sont trop froid notamment face
à sauvian qui est attaqué de toute part
adam d'ailleurs si on prend un f4 c'est
ce qu'a fait craquer ce qui a fait qu'un
mois et 4 on peut pas vraiment reprendre
du pillon puisque ça ouvrir un petit peu
trop le roi blanc est grande il ya au
moins ça complique les choses il faut
garder la colonne est ouverte pour la
tour voilà aussi un principe toujours
d'attaqué on garde la colonne ouverte
pour la tour qui peut toujours attaques
et éventuellement plus tard
cette solution et vii et ce roi qui est
un peu faible avec cette structure
depuis on a un peu cassé
voilà une possibilité dont on garde
cette colonne ouverte et donc on reprend
du wrp rendu fou là il replace sa dame
sera 15 17 alors assez bizarre elle
aurait peut-être dû la laisser
la mettre tout de suite sur la case 17
ce qui l'aurait pas fait une erreur
aussi être ami vladimir kramnik la
position des différents tout à l'heure
quand il a joué au terme des 8
on voit pas trop ce qu'elle faisait en
v8 cette dame de toute façon puisque
il y avait peut-être des cours est à
mézières qui nous échappe tout à l'heure
c'était d'écouter très peur de
découverte de ce fou et d'esters dame
tout contrôle pioncer 6 qui ont attaqué
la dame en même temps c'est possible
alors après tout raté un tour et ce huit
on développe kramnik quand même
développe toutes ces pièces non moi
qu'il a d'énormes problèmes déjà
puisqu'il ya deux pions centraux très
fort une belle paire de fou et ses pions
là qui sont faibles qui sont faible très
faible mais on comprend quand même
d'être pareil on comprend quand même
pourquoi il a pris en f4 parce que là il
a pu quand même replacé un petit peu ces
pièces et ils espèrent ils espèrent que
les pions avant cette nouvelle bannière
les plus adverse pour récupérer ce père
qui va se tromper mais en fait si ses
pions sont quand même énorme parce que
ça ça on voit bien que ça repousse les
noirs qui sont en fait un peu étouffée
moi je peux dans cette position la bombe
alors dis je des coûts et il a t'on
enfin il essaie de tenir et c'est
d'obtenir on est très mal voilà il ne
peut qu'attendre c'est une position
d'attenté pas ce n'est pas faire d'
initiative puisque donc une percée
depuis un an sa disposition s'ils
essaient de jouer
c'est ça qui est bien il peut il peut
prendre des 5 avec quelques gros pions
pas ses protégés il peut aussi
éventuellement se prendre des cinq qui
avait découverte de fou qu'il faut
calculer est-ce que carlier des 5
permettra de sauver sait pas que c'est
pas clair c'est très compliqué chaque
coup topalov à des possibilités de
pousser des scènes de pousser au 5
d'augmenter la pression sur ses six ça
pose d'énormes problèmes en noir c'est
extrêmement difficile à calculer tapas
au total of tintin pollock j'ai failli
topalov fauzy foulée 5 les petites lois
du cavaly puisque dallas il ya quand
même une tour donc menace aux 5 voilà
donc où g5 avec une menace tout
simplement de gagner une pièce donne
assez sages attaquent le cavalier
attaque aussi la transparence se fout ce
pion avec fouille dalle est aussi la
tour derrière du cpie des teintes et qui
ça fait beaucoup donc il faut le 7 avr
cédait pour des clous et voilà on des
clous le cavalier droite rachat d'un bon
sens relève de possibilités donc là il
joue un peu avec la pendule et les nerfs
de crédit quinze jours non jeûnés un
coup prophylactique qui va être utile
c'est clair que le roi est plus à l'abri
sur la case achat il évite les échecs
général déchets sur la grande diagonale
en cadets que ce pion ici centrale
pourra bouger voilà donc trois chiens
cavalli h7 alors qu'harry lâche cette
attaque le fou quand même l'impression
que kramnik c'est l'aube c'est l'heure
de simplifier situation est ce que
voulaient se simplifier ce que
finalement ces plans vont devenir encore
plus fort en ces salles a pas forcément
s'il faut pas donner les cases les cases
noires il faut il faut garder les cages
grecques alors topal choisi de revenir
foot voilà faut 3 beaucoup bougé 5 et la
foulée cinq échanges de ce coup de
proposer un échange de scum évidemment
de topalov garde sa paire de fou voilà
exactement au fuji un extérieur voilà et
là on comprend donc l'idée de courage
rokkaku prophylactique mais voilà qui
finalement a donné la case au foot le
fou a pris la plus drôle à l'accasion
râlant voit très bien que ce pion une
faible puisqu'il est toujours sous la
menace potentielle de ce fou de la dame
on va peut-être plus tard une fois après
avoir chassé ce fou par exemple par h4
peut-être mettre une tour et augmenté la
pression sur ce plan est ce qu'on peut
pas avancer
c'est cents de moins en moins voilà donc
le pion six places et contrôlés par l'ia
cavaliers par le pion à terme il ya un
thème par l'adam il ya un thème qui
définit donc ce genre de
faiblesse on appelle ça une faiblesse
chronique donc le pion c6 qui sera
toujours faibles donc c'était dans les
séries monique non comme une maladie
chronique voilà exactement donc voilà
donc on va dire que le crâne x souffre
du pion
du plan sable qui ont fait blois la
zéolithe la maladie du bios et 6 ouais
c'est une maladie de la position noir
alors cavalier est fluide donc il
replace son cavalier fuite et la topalov
choisit maintenant de jouer le groupe h4
on peut pas là il pose la question aux
fous attention c'est plus fort que lui
en plus c'est au palais obligé de jouer
à coup un coude à coude à coude
excessive dans sa tâche théâtre va
permettre peut-être plus tard de
proposer des h5 mais surtout pose la
question aux fous et la plus le choix
soit il rassure ses des ménages soit sur
celle là mais dans ce cas-là soumettre
un peu renfermé rayonner tout le temps
mais ils contrôlent acacias qui empêche
une tour de venir là peut-être mais je
crois que là dans cette position entre
il n'a pas le choix car il préfère
remettre en 7 et garder la souplesse de
son fou tous les coups sont assez
douteux dans cette position il faut
jouer de son il a plus beaucoup de temps
d'ailleurs il n'a plus beaucoup de temps
parce qu'on a eu 5 et là maintenant
voilà topalov ça y est on voit donc tout
le travail positionne être pas l'eau va
commencer à porter ses fruits après eux
cinq pour la sai et pression sur ses 6
et comment faire pour empêcher la prise
de ce camp c'est pas sale kramnik trouve
une bonne solution il défend avec un cas
médical et v8 mais il est passif ce qui
a valu à huy et pacifique et c'est
extrêmement passive c'est quand même
c'est quand même je suis en défense et
j'essaie de tenir mais ça va être très
difficile
tous parlent à peine 1 re place ces
pièces car les c3 il revient assez
logique il veut très certainement passé
en 4 par exemple ou peut-être pas c'est
peut-être plutôt eu de henri iv car il
le remet son sa pièce une fois qu'elle a
fini son travail à 4 illarramendi parle
près du centre où il est le déclin dit
en même temps vers le roi aussi vers le
roi potentiellement vers l'europe alors
fou bay 4-2 kramnik
gomes trouver un coup pour kramnik le
problème est là c'est que il ne peut
qu'attendre de voir ce que va faire
topalov il est bloqué en quarts manqué
dans cette position on a eu dame j'ai
deux dames j'ai deux attaques avec la
dame donc toujours un oeil sur le sur la
fameuse faiblesse chronique c6 voilà la
dame et le fameux de foot bel bat sur
hexagonal donc d'abaisser 8 les noirs et
vite quand même essayer de préparer
une poussée 5 mai tour c'est un camp qui
interdit pour toujours la poussée du
curé voilà il y aurait trop de risques à
cause d'éventuelles courage c'est de
cavaliers c3 quitter sa case donc hélas
notre avenir qui traquera qu'en donnant
la paire de fou il craque non maintenant
mais là on peut dire c'est la cellule
c'est le dernier point de la partie
graco jouent leurs questions je crois
qu'avec des pièces comme ça
ouais voilà c g knicks avec il est qu'il
allait perdre ni les domine donc il a
joué il avait plus beaucoup de temps il
fallait jouer fallait jouer donc il a
joué ça et maintenant on va voir après
la prise du client normal puisqu'on
consolide notre centre on voit bien que
le centre est maintenant extrêmement
fort puisque tous les pions se tient
c'est vrai c'est dans une phalange
énorme dont une paire de fou un gros
centraux sera un gros un gros centre de
pioncer très difficiles et les cavaliers
vont essayer de faire leur maximum mais
bon là on va voir la halle haas à un
clouage encore une fois un nouveau clou
âge donc le cavalier si les clous et la
colonie qui commence à s'ouvrir qui font
sa note dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
véritablement à s'ouvrir dame ces sept
là on peut pas d'une exécution
dans cette mesure où il s était passé
déjà donc c'était le semis attente on
pensait pas trop si ça me laisse des
choses vraiment pas si sam nasa peut
menacer de jouer ces quatre dessins ce
que sa position ne
n'est pas dangereuse du tout il peut
très bien défendre sont plantés pour
éventuellement préparer ces cas là les
cinq avec les pions c'est pour ça que
les dix-sept kramnik essaie de ramener
son cavalier maintenant
un petit peu en défense et là un coup un
coup assez amusant donc on appelle ça un
changement de cap la dame chabat de vire
de bord elle passe complètement les
dames d'un renvoi qu'on va les blancs
s'amuse que toutes les pièces peuvent
basculer d'un côté de l'autre que toutes
les cases sont contrôlés que là la
position de kramnik est sous une
pression énorme par les caisses à longue
portée il ya que des questions portées
dans l'onglet ils s'amusent mais regarde
quand même les petites images que je
viens de de colorer là on voit bien
quand même que les pièces
convergent convergent vers la même
direction vers 5 heures et 7 et 7 le roi
et le roi donc la pression est énorme la
pression est énorme donc cavalier b6
pour essayer de bloquer pour revenir en
d5 voit l'avenir sur la case des sacs
pour bloquer tour f3 donc pour doubler
maintenant les tours cavaliers fuite et
on double les tours et là alors là ça
fait trop là c'est énorme trois pièces
quand sûr ça fait beaucoup menad a
menacé le 3ème set et on va voir que
savard est pas facile à défendre source
est obligé de recettes fouet trois
maintenant le fou ce réveil de ce fameux
fou qui dormait depuis tout à l'heure à
la règle puisque ils menacent de faire
une une enfilade voilà un de prendre
deux pièces de gagner donc dans la même
diagonale des deux tours sur cette
diagonale là sur la diagonale j'ai cinq
des huit cavaliers h7 est là donc kvh
c'est qui qui empêche évidemment
maintenant le fou de venir ici mais mais
en revenant h7 lecavalier ne protège
plus la case ou 6 et ça donne la
combinaison final on va l'avoir tout
l'art est donc la grande combinaison de
cette neuvième partie fantastique
voilà tout reprend à vii voilà ça y est
c'est la fin le dernier rempart des
noirs diront dirons nous sautent ya plus
rien à faire là y'a plus rien à faire
pourquoi parce que déjà on menace mais
tout reprend tour avec un échec de la
dame
donc il ya pas beaucoup de solutions
pour les noirs la question donc l'acca
de tout reprendre tout ou alors la
question principale c'est que se
passe-t-il après tour pro tour mais tout
simplement pour prendre ton proto et
d'un pro tour quand même temps dans la
tour est attaqué et sur dame prend tour
et bien tout simplement c'est le fou on
voit bien que cavalli qui est sorti ici
on achète ne contrôle plus c'est le fou
qui viennent cloud et la dame qui est
perdu est sûre comme kung fu la dame à
deux points elle fout là voilà
évidemment on prend de la dame échecs et
les assumer avec une tour eiffel avait
dit contre une dame dans une position
complètement qui est à sauver avec les
vêtements catastrophique de toute façon
ces déceptions s'en trouveront largement
facilement faire la différence
donc cramique après tout reprend excède
tente encore quelques coups on va voir
que c'est des coups désespérés qu'à
l'aller des cinq mais un peu tard
maintenant pour bloquer la diagonale de
la dame
et après tout recettes f3 tout
simplement s'est pas trop posé de
questions tout pas là qu'il y avait un
autre coup plus fort en fait dans cette
position c'était faux 6 voilà voilà le
coup qui était possible parce que
surtout reprend fou évidemment c'est la
dame qui est en prise et on menace
toujours de faire un échec au revoir à
la découverte en prenant la tour donc le
seul coût qui reste sept tours caen pour
et après tout reprend f7 il ya plus de
choix parce que la table la dame est
perdu en fait parce que si la dame par
par exemple ont des huit tv tout
simplement tourner cet échec on rompt
avec le fou enfin bon gléau prochaine
comprend dans la norme c'est important
de le voir cette possibilité c'est
important mais à ce niveau si on regarde
la partie on voit qu'après cavaliers des
cinq tours et aux cèdres war 3 et alice
est mort y'a plus rien il ya
matériellement il ya un pion - mais il
ya donc il ya déjà avions de plus pour
les blancs l'albert de fouiller un gros
centres de pouvoir faut voir la
structure les noirs des faiblesses des
parts que des cycles des cibles qui vont
tomber quand des fruits exactement donc
de protéger ses pions ils sont
complètement out très belle partie que
de voir leurs amis cameron et puis puis
stoppé l'offre donc qui prend l'avantagé
5-4 ouais mais très belle partie très
mal parti quelle belle maestria quelle
domination qu'elle sceptique même ccc on
pensait qu topalov était peut-être plus
tacticien que kramnik mais là c'est
positionne langue qu'il a dominé wigan
est maintenant c'est clair c'est clair
là ils avaient l'initiative c'était
quand même quelqu'un qui est très très
fort pour garder l'initiative et puis
donc topalov qui comme à son habitude se
réveille enfin en fin de compétition
fait une condition alors il reste plus
que trois parties il mène au score
maintenant 1-0 gagnent dominé de
l'écraser on peut dire que ça y est le
match est plié jean-luc mois il faut
attendre faut attendre
on va voir ce que votre chronique
indique encore deux fois les blancs
ouais mais est ce que c'est possible de
revenir comme ça il l'avait déjà fait
contre les colas il a eu trois fois les
noirs y ait eu cette histoire de point
par forfait maintenant il se prend deux
raclées de suite et une fois avec les
normes à une fois avec les blancs une
fois maintenant avec les mots il se fait
complètement dominé est ce qu'il aura le
mental est ce que si possible de revenir
dans une situation comme ça un joueur
qui a battu l'écho et kasparov je pense
que est capable de trouver des
ressources
que d'autres n'ont pas on va voir ça on
verra ça lors de l'analyse de la 10e
partie avec toi toujours jean luc sur
cette dixième partie pour la suite de ce
match fantastique
est-ce que kramnik va réussir à en
revenir on n'y croit pas on croit que le
match est terminé et que topalov va
prendre ce titre réunifiée à trois
parties de la fin il a dominé un petit
peu cranie qui lui a mis la pression
horrifique et avec cette histoire est
maintenant sur l'échiquier y mène au
score
mais évidemment fausse km jusqu'au bout
il reste encore trois parties il faut
voir la suite